I came to be a partner
at YC actually because I
was also someone who went
through the program myself.
I went through Y Combinator
in the Winter of 2006,
the first batch out here in California
and I founded a company called Wufoo.
Wufoo was an online forum builder,
it helps create online surveys,
power event registration, and
process simple online payments.
Ran that company for five years and we
then sold that to Survey Monkey in 2011.
Interesting thing about that company,
it is not your typical type
of Silicon Valley company.
After we raised our funding,
after demo day, we purposely
only raised about $100,000 and
then we moved back to Florida on the
east coast and we operated out of there.
We never had a centralized office so
it's complete remote working team, and
we only grew the company to
about ten people, on purpose.
There was a lot of money offered to us,
but we were relatively profitable
as a startup, so we never needed to take
any money from venture capitalists or
any other investors at the time.
And when we were acquired,
one of the interesting metrics
that sometimes we talk about is that
the average company that sold, or
required, or went IPO that year was
about, had raised $25 million and
their average returns to their
investor was about 600%.
Wufoo only raised $100,000 for
the life of the company and
our returns to our investor was like,
29,000%.
So, a lot of what I work on with
companies that like combinators is
focusing on building the kind of company
that doesn't need to raise money from
other people and
being extremely efficient and
productive with the resources
they have at hand.